my name is rick irani and i am the
editor-in-chief of the journal of
international affairs on behalf of the
editorial and faculty advisory boards of
the journal and our co-sponsors at the
Earth Institute I would like to thank
you for joining us this evening for our
thought leadership forum on innovating
for development the theme of innovation
and its profound impact on international
relations made its debut in the pages of
the journal of international affairs in
1959 with the publication of our spring
issue science and world politics the
editors of that issue referred to their
era as the Atomic Age saying that it is
in the realm of scientific techniques of
inspection and control that man can
presently see his greatest hopes for
survival amidst the means of total
destruction this statement is worth
recalling even today as government's
from around the globe gather in Cancun
to discuss how they can address the
impacts of manmade climate change more
than ever before the world has at its
disposal a dynamic arsenal of tools for
the achievement of development goals in
recent years we've seen the novel use of
mobile technology to promote public
health in Haiti we've seen in real time
the utility of open-source mapping in
humanitarian emergencies and across the
world governments are making dramatic
investments in greener energy
technologies to help mitigate the
effects of greenhouse gas emissions
tonight the journal is proud to announce
the launch of its fall winter 2010 issue
innovating for development this issue of
the journal critically examines the what
innovation can and cannot do in the
context of sustainable development it
highlights not just the use of
innovative technologies but the policies
structures and incentives that
facilitate its diffusion and transfer
contributions to this issue cover a wide
range of topics including technology
transfer one laptop per child the role
of universities in promoting global
public health and the impact of
copyright systems on economic
development
I am pleased to welcome our
distinguished panelists who will be
addressing some of these and other
important issues in their discussion
tonight in particular tonight's
discussion will focus on how innovation
is driving the agenda for climate change
natural resource use and energy policy
but before we begin our discussion this
evening I'd like to ask for your
indulgence for a moment in thanking a
few people without whom whose support
tonight's event would not be possible on
behalf of the editorial board I'd like
to extend our sincere gratitude to the
this issue's contributors one of whom
mr. David reason I'm we are honored to
have here tonight we would also like to
thank our esteemed advisory board Dean
Coatsworth and the administration here
at sefa we'd also like to thank
professor scott barrett who served as
advisor on this issue and everyone in
cpit external communications and
facilities for their instrumental
support finally to all of our editorial
production and digital assistants I know
many of you are here tonight we cannot
thank you enough for your dedication
moderating our discussion tonight is dr.
Steven Cohen executive director and
chief operating officer of the Earth
Institute over the past three decades
dr. Cohen has been at the forefront of
thinking on Environmental Policy and
sustainable development after spending
several years at the Environmental
Protection Agency dr. Cohen joined the
Columbia University faculty and has
since played a crucial role in building
programs here at ciba and at the Earth
Institute his work truly income
encapsulate the idea of innovating for
development and we are very honored to
have him moderating our discussion
tonight dr. Cohen welcome thank you
and I want to thank the journal for
providing us with these very comfortable
chairs i think the palace that i may be
taking a nap here it a little while if
we're not we don't really liven things
up for you so well today we're going to
talk with you about the whole issue of
innovation development and in the role
of technology technology is what has
created all of these wonders like the
nuclear power just heard about too cheap
to meter was the expression i think they
used back then or as Barry commoner once
put it a hell of a complicated way to
boil water technology is both what's
created this wonderful lifestyle that
many of us enjoy and has also created
these problems that we have to address
and in today's panel is going to talk
about the use of technology and
innovation how do we bring technologies
into our economy how do we solve the
problems that humanity faces through the
use of hopefully creative and innovative
technology we were talking downstairs
before I was thinking about how
complicated this issue is and how
unpredictable technologies are Paul and
I were talking about the cell phone
nobody would have predicted two decades
ago that the average student at sepa
would not have a telephone landline in
their apartment but in fact would have a
cell phone instead and it's just a small
indicator of how difficult it is to
predict the future when it comes to
technology and we'll be hearing more
about that let me quickly get to
introduce our distinguished panel you
all have a program i believe yes
everybody here have a program so i'm not
going to read through everything about
these folks because you can do that
yourself but Professor Driessen who
you've just heard about is a university
professor at Syracuse and he works on
the economic dynamics of Environmental
Law he's in fact an environmental lawyer
and an excellent one who has written
about environmental policy and some very
compelling
interesting way since we'll be hearing
from him seated next to him is
somebody's familiar with to see past
students because he's a visiting
professor professor pin yo who has come
to us from Portugal where for from 2005
to 2009 he was the minister of economy
and innovation and a member of the
parliament and so here we have both an
academic and a policymaker and seated
next to him is another distinguished
visitor from Europe a professor to be
Anna who is both the founder of the
Institute for sustainable development in
international relations in Paris but
also from 1997 to 2002 served as a
senior advisor to a prime minister
Lionel adjustment on environmental
issues and so we have another
distinguished practitioner academic as
part of our panel next next to her is my
colleague from the earth and student
from the engineering school the director
of Columbia's a water centre a professor
model ow who is one of the most creative
and interesting thinkers on global water
problems that we have and is thought
long and hard about the use of
technology to solve the world's water
problems and last but not least at the
very end is a professor Paul hudnut who
is co-director of Colorado State's
global innovation center for energy
health and environment he also is a
lawyer and one who is working on crucial
energy and environmental issues and so
what we're going to the format of the
panel is each of our panelists will
speak with you for five minutes and
offer their perspective then I'm going
to try to get them to fight with each
other a little bit liven things up then
I'm going to invite you to argue with us
and tell us why we're all hopelessly out
of date so we'll start immediately to my
left ok what I want to talk with about
very briefly in five minutes is about
trying to get technology transfer to
developing countries for addressing
climate disruption and the key vision
here is you know people would love to
see a leapfrog effect
we're developing countries would move to
clean technologies that having to go
through the dirty ones but the key
developing countries here like China and
India already have lots of dirty
technology so it's going to be more
complicated than that but everybody
agrees that this is at the heart of the
challenges if we can get the kind of
technological transfer in developing
countries as well as in developed
countries to address climate disruption
and it's absolutely essential both for
sustainable development and economic
development because if we don't address
this properly we're going to have big
economic problems both because climate
disruption itself is an economic
calamity and because fossil fuel will
run out and before it runs out it's
going to become very expensive and wreak
economic havoc that way so we really
need to do this the question is how and
they're two basic governance mechanisms
that try to address technology transfer
to developing countries a trade we might
call them trade and aid the trade model
is used in the clean development
mechanism in the Kyoto Protocol where
the idea is that developed countries
will fund projects in developing
countries in lieu of local reductions
that they would otherwise be obligated
to make so that's the Clean Development
Mechanism where people get out of their
emission reduction obligations locally
by funding projects in developing
countries and that's a means of
technology transfer the other another
means we also see in the Kyoto Protocol
but it's more cause more robust in the
Montreal Protocol is a government aid
model and there you have an
international institution with
government funds used to fund
technologies abroad and so our task is
to mail these things or choose the right
one in some way and i would say that
there are three big policy attributes
you have to look for this to work
positive spillover scale and
additionality i want to talk briefly
about each of these things and the CDM
in particular the CDM never adds
emission reductions net it is always
about trade so you always give up
something to get one so there's no
environmental value the Clean
Development Mechanism
there was a cost-effectiveness value
unless there's a positive spillover that
is unless by doing a project in
developing country you increase people's
knowledge and capacity increase the
possibility of developing countries
enacting climate disruption policies as
some have China has a strict standards
for vehicles and there are other
policies abroad that have tried to do
that and we need more of that so
positive spillover is very important the
other thing is a scale and this is why
we recognize the international community
to have an influence it's not enough to
have a few projects going on I mean if
we're building a coal-fired power plant
every week and we have a few renewable
energy projects going along on the side
that isn't good enough so this have to
be massive increases the scale of
technology transfer and that for that
reason it's likely that the
international regime will continue with
the CDM and add some kind of aid
component if they can come up with the
financing finally additionality now this
has been a big problem with the CDM that
is the first thing that people do is not
new innovation in a trading program they
try to get credit for what they've
already done and it's been hard to
police that so the net effect is you
lose emission reductions because people
get credit for what they're going to do
anyway instead of for new projects and
that's a big challenge for the CDM and
there's a comparable problem of waste
that could arise an international in an
international aid model so additionality
is a problem that is the idea is you
want each project you find that you give
up at a mission reduction in Europe for
to be an additional new project not just
project developer capitalizing on
something that's already been funded in
the developing country so by way of of
summary we have these two models of a
trade program exemplified by CDM or
potential aid model or government come
up with the money rather than the
private sector in any model you need
positive spill overs you need to have
increases in local knowledge and
capacity coming out of technology
transfer you need a much bigger scale of
technology transfer to have an impact on
the main trends in developing countries
and you need an addition a latino to see
to it the projects that are that are
being purchased with emission credits
are actually adding something and not
just claiming for credit for it's
already being done sir pinion thank you
see well first of all I would like to
say that I'm delighted to be here at the
firm of the journal of international
affairs I thank you for inviting me I've
been a visiting professor at CPAC for
this last semester who's coming to an
end this was a great experience to me
and what has impressed me the most was
the great quality of the students and
your interest in energy policy energy
and environment are for sure one of the
top challenges of the 21st century
energy the demand for energy increased
by and I'll use some units five thousand
millions of tons of oil equivalent in
the last twenty years and is supposed to
increase by the sign over the next 25
years so this means that energy demand
will increase by twenty five percent
over the next 20 years ninety-five of
this increase will come from non-oecd
countries so this will be a matter of
China China and China then fossil fuels
represent eighty percent of energy
consumption like it or not so in 10
years in 30 years in 50 years we'll be
here discussing how to replace fossil
fuels but we'll be speaking about them
because something that is a law is that
fuel cycles are extremely wrong call
took more than 100 years to replace
biomass and then oil took 100 years to
replace go so now it won't be in the
neck
five or ten years that we will be able
to live without fossil fuels at the same
time we have this energy challenge we
have an environment challenge I mean
there is absolutely no doubt of the
close correlation between co2
concentrations and that global
temperature of the planet and it's
disturbing that what we have witnessing
over the last 100 years has been not
witnessed over the last 5,000 years and
the increase in co2 emissions is
man-made and seventy-five percent of
that is related to energy so there is an
extremely close connection between
energy and the environment something
that has surprised me the most here is
that there is a kind of ideology debate
between energy and the environment so
it's a kind of debate between left and
right I would say that it is rather a
debate of right and wrong because what
we need is action and we need action now
to create a new energy era I call it a
new energy era e.r.a efficiency e are
renewable energy and a advanced thermal
generation and that is the name of a
plant that Europe has approved called
the set plan the technology plan for
energy and become too technology the
main messages of this plan are the
following first there is no silver
bullet there is no miracle solution to
create a sustainable relation between
the environment and energy but we have
already technologies that are extremely
close to do the job then all the sectors
must be involved yes I mean it's not
only a matter of energy it of
electricity transportation it's a matter
of all the sectors that create that the
the society now we can quantify the new
energy era the new energy era will be
fifty percent energy efficiency twenty
percent renewable energy and thirty
percent advanced thermal generation and
by this we can include the new oil plays
carbon capture and storage supercritical
coal power plants third generation
nuclear will need this and as humanity
was able in the 19th century to produce
an industrial revolution that has led to
unprecedented growth in living standards
I'm sure that again without debates of
left and right we'll be able again to
meet this challenge thank you thank you
doctor to be Anna thank you Steve again
I would certainly repeat the extreme
pleasure I had to be a visiting
professor at ciba it wasn't a wonderful
fall with the student center and really
a wonderful experience to discuss with
colleagues so CPI is somehow an
addiction when you begin to come here as
I knew you long to come back so so i'm
finishing like my colleague aziz fall
but i will be very happy to be in touch
with the student my tone even come back
so i think that's you your program is
really functioning to do have people
come back i'll make sure the Dean has
heard that and turns it into a
commitment yeah so I will not repeat so
it was excellent or to first
introduction as being just yesterday
about this morning even in Cancun in the
cup 16 I would like to point some
elements of the political economy of the
discussion on technology transfer and
cooperation and maybe first it is it has
been conceived from the beginning
technology transfer as a prize to to
have really to pay for and have the
developing countries on board on the
decarbonisation of the economy or more
because that was it is a very long-term
goal to have the developing countries
line with the ideas that combating
climate change could be a development
Polly
c2 and and I looking back at the
convention in 1992 kyoto protocol and
and the painful discussion from bally 22
nowadays we see that development is now
in that good more and more at the center
of the climate talks and technology of
both plays and a central role to to to
sort of to convince countries that they
can have a different energy mix and a
different demand for energy diamond
structure but even if it's sort of a
very good and an essential dimension of
the climate talks it has in a way we
played very much against having
timetables and targets for a number of
the geometers technology has been seen
as a way to avoid commitments on the
levels of emissions of course not
talking about the small developing
countries which which are the only thing
they have is to increase our mission at
the first stage but talking about of
course a United States China and even
less developed country like India or
South Africa technology has been seen as
a way to avoid commitments on the global
emission on global emission targets and
that it has introduced in a way I think
damaging element on the discussion on
technology cooperation but we can come
back to that again but part for example
of the preceding is a bush
administration has been to try to have a
discussion on technology not to have the
discussion on the targets and but now
things are getting in a way better
because everybody sees that we need to
have if I follow the professor we need
to have this industrial revolution
nobody has the solution the technology
solution it's much more about gigantic
efforts of technology cooperation to
break really to have breakthrough in
solar energy in renewable energy in
general in Seoul in particular in their
storage of electricity
well a number of issues where we don't
know the responses and where technology
corporation will play a major role so
from a sort of a way of avoiding a
discussion on how countries will commit
to targets we are slowly entering in a
much more positive mood which is we need
that in the short revolution how we
organize together or how we compete
together to produce this new new
technology but we came back on this tech
corporation versus competition aspect
which is playing a very strong role but
the issue is what we see is there there
are now countries like India and China
and Korea in particular and really
through public spendings research and
development programs and public
procurement are really giving signal
that they believe in this clean energy
future but on the other side we see in
spite of these very positive
developments we see huge problems of
deployment of these technologies and
operating around two dimensions first is
of course the problem of decarbonizing
the energy mix and the second is about
controlling zz's energy demand curves
and evolutions and that is very much
about upfront finance for a number of
countries even to really control energy
demand is about infrastructure policy
energy efficiency in the building urban
planning model to avoid a cost in
immobility and transport but in a way a
lot more attention is paid in this
technology cooperation debate on the
high high hand of the technology
electric vehicle CCS is now more at the
core of the discussion on technology
more than the problems of deployment and
of course because many problem of the
appointment is about finance and finally
I would sort of many raise the idea that
a lot would be
on the policy design very much and I
finished with that the idea was with a
strong carbon price we will have this
technology deployment and now we will
realize that this ease of you it's a
sort of a very theoretical view of how
things are we need policy that can allow
technology to deploy these policies are
the cost we have a transition costs of
faith for decoding decarbonizing these
energy mix and that is really then the
technology links with a discussion of
finance like it was set on the CDM but
much much more with a bigger scale to
allow this thank you okay thank you
professor Lau this is an interesting
discussion and I think I'm going to take
it in a slightly different direction at
the beginning of this session there was
a remark that when the ji a issue
originally came out it was the Atomic
Age when it was the Atomic Age it was
pretty clear that you needed Superman
and it was pretty clear that you needed
kryptonite to balance out Superman it
what I'm getting at is that the
double-edged sword of technology was
made very clear at that time in the case
that we were discussing here now with
carbon we are this has been a slower
discovery part but it's a similar story
and today i would say that what you're
going to get taken through largely
because of the rate at which our
populations have grown thanks to
technology again is um the alphabet trip
okay the alphabet trip starts with
uranium you sulfur is carbon sea water
age for example we cut it short nitrogen
and phosphorus p and the point I'm
making is all of these are things that
we think we need we do the same elements
end up as either things that we are
short of or things that are going to
cause us harm in some way but these are
all fundamental to technology and
today's technology rather than the
atomic technology is headed towards
nanotechnology and biomimicry so instead
of Superman if you want something a nice
little doll for your kid
you probably are thinking of nano frames
which is pretty good because you can
imagine them right these are 10 to the
minus 9 meter creatures so you can get
lots of them for your little kid the
story here is the following if you look
at the problem that everybody is
discussing today its carbon and climate
but fundamentally the story of humanity
is one where we have managed to creep
past whatever anybody thought would
limits on sustainability through
advances made on a specific constraint
that was emerging at the time the
constraint that people are pointing to
today is a renewable energy source my
argument is that well before that we are
going to start running into the food
water constraint these are all
interdependent but we will see that and
we are already seeing that in places
that are densely populated and have high
variability in natural renewable water
supply namely India and China so if you
talk to the Chinese and you bring up the
point that Professor Pena did about
their energy constraint they actually
have a more fundamental food constraint
ultimately I would actually argue that
they have solved that constraint more
better than India because they have a
better population growth strategy so
there's that a piece of it which will
work now if I'm saying that we will hit
that constraint before we hit a
constraint posed by climate then I have
to advance some arguments as to how
technology is going to get us out of
that because of course our goal is to be
a thousand billion people on this planet
because most people love to live beyond
their means are create technological
bubbles create financial bubbles and and
then watch them burst and move to the
next one so how are we going to solve
the water problem and how are we going
to solve the food problem the biomimicry
angle and the nano angle come into play
here are today we have technology is
available that can allow you to dial up
a protein of your choice you want
chicken you want wheat protein you can
have that and all you need for this is
solar energy salt water nitrogen from
the atmosphere
and carbon dioxide in a concentrated
stream okay there's many such things
floating around there which bring up the
question of whether that product would
be something you are willing to eat
there are products their technologies
out there today that say that we can
start growing rice which is the largest
water consumer by the way in places like
India forty to sixty percent of the
total electricity in the agricultural
areas goes for pumping groundwater okay
similarly much of the energy used for
producing fertilizer is what what gives
you the high food output that we have
today so if we can get around all of
these issues we have a magical solution
so people have them if you can go and
grow rice in the ocean margin using salt
water um that takes away the water
problem because that's one of the
largest consumers can we do it yes it's
done now okay so the thing is the
question that was put before us is
what's the relationship between
technology and development and to try to
sum up my argument I'll say that
technology is development technology
also poses the constraints of
development because what we have
repeatedly found is that each advance
that we make leads us to a new
constraint which we solve so will we get
to a thousand billion people I think so
i think that is how we got to this
planet because we ruin the previous
planet we were on with a thousand
billion people and somehow migrated here
and there are very very many stories of
how you can argue that happened but the
fact of it is that i think growth will
happen I and development is synonymous
with growth to a certain extent at the
Earth Institute we talk about
sustainable development which many
people will argue is an oxymoron because
sustainability is viewed as a paradigm
which is status quo and we have learned
that that's simply not what it is we are
going to evolve and we'll have ups and
downs and we'll have evolution all
through there the goal of sustainable
development really should be to minimize
the downs as we are going up and with
that I will stop and pause one ok first
you heard that sometimes I sit on these
panels and
wonder it's so interesting to hear my
fellow panelists I'd love to try this
addiction to see / at some point in the
future but I guess it's just starting
tonight so this is a gateway program
absolutely a gateway forum so our big
questions were kind of around this issue
of our is there an opportunity to kind
of leapfrog technologies particularly in
the developing world and then how might
technology be adapted or applied in a
local context and then whether there's a
tension between I guess the question
assume there was a tension between
sustainable and economic development
which professor loll just spoke about my
role is is I guess to be a spokesperson
for the private sector which is kind of
interesting because usually if i'm on a
panel like this i mean i'm an
entrepreneur i work with you know early
stage companies and so usually there's
someone from a really big company but if
they're there they're being very quiet
tonight so so I guess I'll just preface
my remarks by saying when I talk about
what I do I am NOT a large company
innovator and that's important stuff too
and for sustainability to happen those
folks have to be at the table and they
have to be incented properly I guess I
see the entrepreneurs more as the
yapping dogs or the mammals around the
stumbling dinosaurs as we as we close
out this this era so i guess if looking
at the overall title for this program of
innovating for development and
understanding the role of technology I
guess what I would hasten to add is
whenever you hear about innovation and
it's mostly focusing on technology
you're missing part of the conversation
and that part of the conversation is the
one about a dissemination model or a
business model so there are huge numbers
of what we call technology roadkill out
there which is technologies that have
been launched without thinking through
for instance whether people want the
technology these are kind of
technologies that are good for you
but you don't know it and we see a lot
of that in our work and I think part of
the approach there is is some great work
that is being done by folks like Stu
Hart at Cornell or Amy Smith at MIT
which is looking much more what they
would call indigenous creation or models
where you're not imposing a technology
into the developing world but you're
creating it with the developing world
and this very robust conversation that
can happen where there may be people who
know more about kind of the technology
paintbox but others that need to that
are much more aware of the local context
and needs and so and maybe a really
interesting thing to think about to put
out there is we've seen recently with a
dat what's happened when free food comes
in and displaces the agricultural system
that was there and yet I think sometimes
again with the best of intentions people
are eliminating the the creative
Catholic capacity building and design
capacity of people if they're imposing
technologies that were developed here so
to take an example if you have
tremendous nanotechnology and you've got
a great application of carbon nanotubes
for cleaning water your tendency here is
to go work on that invention and maybe
do a TED talk and all these wonderful
things that get us a lot of but first
it's very important to go and find like
is clean water the thing if those people
had ten dollars each per month extra
would they spend on clean water or would
they spend it on education so
understanding how they want to make
choices i think is is important and it's
incredibly hard i don't pretend to be an
expert i tend to be someone who knows
it's important and is trying to figure
out how to do that this this idea of and
so maybe i can give you a couple
examples and then we can get into the
more general questions so the work that
I've been doing the most is in to come
who coincidentally have similar sounding
names and that's an accident not on
purpose the first is enviro fit and what
we have done is designed improved
cookstoves sometimes called clean
cookstoves but they aren't clean they're
just much cleaner than the alternative
which is cooking with a three-stone fire
so traditional cooking with biomass is
about half the world's population and it
tends to be very rudimentary fuels
agricultural waste dung charcoal that's
made in just about the most horrific Lee
unsustainable ways possible and so I
guess we could take the approach of
saying how do we come up with a super
systemic and systemic approach or we
could say let's just figure out a way to
make a cleaner cook stove which is what
we've done and we've designed that with
a lot of work in southern India doing
research going into homes asking how do
you use your stove what do you cook
what's important to you and we're now
selling cook stoves in southern India
and about to move into Africa and at a
pace of a hundred thousand cook stoves a
year hopefully scaling that up so we've
scaled up from small-scale but we're
still not huge to give you just some
idea of numbers Apple last year sold its
one hundred millionth ipod the world
demand for cook stoves is estimated to
be 500 million cook stoves so I've just
got to figure out how to sell five times
more cook stoves than apples sold iPods
just to kind of give you an idea of kind
of the so this idea of how technologies
disseminate and how they move out and
how markets help with that is is an area
that I'm still very much a student and
and I encourage most everyone who works
in this area that the attitude of being
a student as opposed to an expert is the
right way to approach it and I'll stop
there okay thank you let me make a
couple of observations then I have a
couple of questions to start us off on
one is how unpredictable technology and
diffusion can be one of the biggest
public policy problems we had in New
York City the beginning of the 20th
century was horse manure it was all over
Manhattan lower Manhattan you needed
boots to get around and nobody would
have predicted that the solution was
something called a horseless carriage
but there it is twenty years later
there's no more horse manure now we have
other problems but that problem was
eliminated nobody would have predicted
as I said earlier twenty years ago there
would be five billion cell phones on the
planet today nobody knew we needed them
but obviously my teenage daughter can't
live without it so clearly it was a
necessity I never understood but how did
that technology get disseminated
developed disseminated marketed and
brought all over the world and in
incredibly rapid order or the ipod
another technology none of us knew we
needed 3,000 songs in our pocket at
every moment so that's one side of the
equation the other side is demographers
talk about sociologists talk about a
demographic transition where children in
traditional societies are an economic
necessity you have them because they're
your social security they work the farm
they help take care of you when you're
old and so forth and then as those of us
who have college-age children no
children become what sociologists call
decorative they're not an economic
necessity in fact we have them because
of emotion but they're not going to
actually help us survive economically
and that of course leads to the
demographic transition where note we're
in places like Japan you're no longer
even replacing your population it's also
a problem or an issue in Europe so those
are a couple of observations the third
one is actually the point that you were
making about sustainability we had Bill
Gates visit the Earth Institute last
year and he said I don't like the word
sustainability so do I want to sustain a
billion people in extreme poverty around
the world that's not what we're after
we're after something else
so but then he said but I can't think of
a better word for preserving the planet
while we do all of that but the
fundamental question I want the panel to
be thinking about is as we think about
sustainable development or least
development that doesn't destroy the
planet and we think about technology how
do we get a handle on what is realistic
in the development of Technology and how
do we get a handle on using public
policy to accelerate the process of
diffusion so I think those are fair
questions and we could go straight down
the line here or I could take somebody
who'd like to volunteer to address it
first well I'll be I'll be happy to
address any oh yeah I won't have any
time to think but I'll I'll speak anyway
ok hi I guess the question you close
with is how we're going to deal with
diffusion how we're going to get
diffusion what sort of policies need I
think the first point is that we do need
policies that is this isn't like the
ipod because this is collective but it's
not even like a cook stove where you're
protecting your own environment it's a
collective problem so it's going to need
policy and I think that's an elementary
point that actually is neglected in some
of the earlier economic analysis of
climate change where there's sort of an
assumption that technology can evolve
without government support in this area
and I don't think that's true how to do
it is tricky and its cultural specific
and it's especially tricky because of
the unpredictability that you highlight
it's still true that it's unpredictable
how these technologies will evolve the
first thing to say is we can get
diffusion of a lot without even getting
into innovation and change I mean right
now around the world there are zero
carbon models in some societies close to
a zero carbon utility sector in France
because of advanced nuclear design you
have very very low carbon emissions in
Brazil in the transport sector because
of advanced relatively advanced biofuels
so there are things that we know how to
do it's a matter of getting policies in
place
to make them happen with renewable
energy so far the most effective thing
has been these feed-in tariffs where you
offer a high price for renewables and
you know the other with nuclear the
thing has been absolutely rigid state
control so that the designs chosen by
the state so that in fact there is no
room for the private sector to screw up
with accidents because there's no you
have a common design so you know so
there's no one model and it's a real
complicated question how you get the
government market mix right because the
advocates of missions training or kind
of right that there are a lot of
business people come up with cool ideas
and want to give them incentives to do
them on the other hand they're not going
to take care of the risk risk problem of
some of these things the government is
going to have to do that and they're not
going to do anything that's expensive
they may do something on the on the
energy efficiency side I'm not going to
anything expensive unless you have taxes
or the cap or some kind of significant
policy in place to make it worthwhile
Lawrence did you have something just to
building on on what you said and in
taking the example of France it's
Ventress ting because we had of course
this eighty percent of electricity out
of the nuclear sector nuclear power
plants and we engage like many other
countries in Europe to develop a
renewable program basically a su feed-in
tariff so high price for electricity out
of solar and wind power and and there
you see the complex mix between unique
policies it was of course and then it
was said I was in the government at that
time when we decided for the feed-in
tariffs for the solar energy and wind
energy and you could have said always it
started a process we will have the
centralized power production and then we
need the next step is to him to need
very good grids and in smart grids to
use this capacity and to combine this
two very different models heavily
centralized with a very decentralized
and so the story could be was nice and
supported by the European policy and
supported by climate talks and and you
see that this construction about how you
create in a well system link to is of
course obviously it was the government
driven policies and some actors really
betting on that and then from a certain
because at one stage you you you begin
to make the cost and benefit analysis
and then because of this uncertainty
around should we go really to the
low-carbon economy then all the system
is really getting not destroyed but with
a lot of problems now in France you have
a number of economic actors screaming
that we will have to get free to the
renewable policy we don't need needs is
that the emission trading market in
European efficient not giving signal
enough to really to invest for these new
new energy sources and so in a way you
see policies are very necessary but the
steadiness the resilience of the policy
the long-term aspect is key when you
have investment cycle and of course
energy is a very long investment cycle
you as you said you don't switch from
one year to another one so I think I see
the problem where because there is a lot
of uncertainty or that's really we can
go to this low carbon economy that's
really the perspective you have a lot of
policies who seems very solid and now we
can be changed from not from one day and
it's all a bit really be undermined and
that's nice think the main problem we
have it's about an Israel Industrial
Revolution but can we have the policy
signals that can last and in a way I
missoula Turkish enough I think if we
think about the policy signals and then
you know you look at say the French
political structure and the US political
structure being
radically different of I don't and
Portuguese I'm not sure I don't know
enough about the structure there but
you've got incredible variation in
motivating the private sector incredible
variation political culture and
structure so clearly you've got to talk
about a multiplicity of approaches that
will vary by location we're not going to
get in the United States a single model
for a nuclear power plant that would get
through 50 state governments with any
you know unless we have a national
emergency and we nationalize energy
production which I don't think that the
people that just took over the house of
representatives are going to permit so I
guess my question is to the panel what
do you think how do we deal with this
relationship between government and the
private sector with all of these
variables but I keep on saying that
although Portugal is an example in
renewable energy worldwide we have not
used one dime of public money and my
belief is that without full
participation of the private sector this
change cannot happen but what change are
we talking about if we go back to my e
ra hear a story this is 50% energy
efficiency 25% renewable energy and
let's put it twenty-five percent
mobility ballpark figures so the fifty
percent of energy efficiency it's not a
breakthrough it must be tens or hundreds
of small improvements in technology
because we are talking about improvement
improving the efficiency of buildings
households schools industry and this
will be like it or not fifty percent of
the savings in energy and co2 emissions
it's not glamorous but it's this small I
mean efficient lamps better windows is
50% then one quarter for renewable
energies they are there you have wind
wind is fantastic and with competition
in feed-in tariffs you almost
are at grid the parity at the same time
for example wind technology has improved
substantially in the in the last decades
now so I don't believe in a breakthrough
I believe in this small step in existing
technologies then mobility mobility I
mean we are close to 2nd generation
biofuels but we have I breeds and we are
extremely close to electrical mobility
so it is possible in my view we don't
need a breakthrough like the mobile
because if we need it we would go to the
problem in Europe you know that Europe
not only invests very little in R&D but
if they put ninety percent on nuclear
why energy policy tends to be dominated
by the interest of nuclear companies
French companies that in my view will
not lead anywhere and i repeat the
calculation fifty percent energy
efficiency twenty percent renewable
energy twenty-five percent mobility so
it's the addition of several small steps
forward but we are very close to to to
to to go there now without political
will without policies change will not
happen okay then they will get tomorrow
okay okay um yet just building on it I
think something even simpler about the
European model is that another twenty
percent renewable target but there isn't
so everybody agrees on that so you have
a framework but then individual
countries have a lot of freedom to
decide how to do that so if you look
across Europe you can see what they call
green quotas and we call renewable
portfolio standards which are quantities
standards say you have to have a certain
percentage of renewables but other
countries use these feed-in tariffs
where you have a high price for the
renewable energy and the quantity is a
little more unpredictable and some
countries use hybrids of this so there
are a lot of variants in approach and I
would argue that used to be the
predominant means of
tional environmental law and one of the
novelties may be one of the unfortunate
things in the kyoto protocol is to push
so hard on the particular policy
mechanism emissions trading is the way
to do things in Europe you know which
was probably more inclined to taxation
initially went along with this part of
his taxation was difficult and to fit
into the free trade regime but but you
know partly for the sake of having
international cooperation on mechanisms
but that may be more important to have
international women goals and then
diversity on mechanisms did you want to
get it I'm not a policy person so let me
preface things with that but if you are
making policies I think additionally as
I understand it there are two main goals
to stimulate a particular direction or
to regulate a certain outcome and these
things can work fairly effectively but
even as this conversation shows
typically policymakers focus on one goal
one outcome at a time and this is a
problem because if you look in the real
world situation you have you need to be
carbon neutral you need to be water
neutral you need to be nitrogen neutral
and we are going to run out of
phosphorus we need to watch out for that
and there isn't a strategy or a
discussion so we move to biofuels or
renewable and hence this is good until
we realize that okay they are going to
zap all the water supplies in a
particular place so that's you know the
way we have sort of done things in the
past over the last few years I've come
to the realization that the world is
only seemingly run by politicians
perhaps it's actually done by
multinationals and it's not clear to me
who runs them it's not run by anybody I
don't know if anybody's told you this
year as near as I can tell it's chaos
right but but I think the other thing i
guess i would i would point to is that
it isn't the public policy tries to
solve problems that he tries to make
them look bad right I understand so I
think in a sense what Professor Kenya
was saying small-scale change does tend
to be what happens except when once in a
while something interesting happens like
somebody invents
a national power solution as we saw in
France somebody invents a solution to
all the horse manure or our in other
word she sometimes do see technologies
have effects on the political economy of
an area in ways that nobody would have
predicted nobody would have predicted
that the interstate highway system was
going to result in suburban sprawl but
it did right no I agree that's what I
was sort of going to is that if you look
at the current error what every
multinational is trying to do is to
argue that they are actually carbon
neutral water neutral etc they're moving
in that direction because the bar has
been set in a sense and so what I'm
driving at is that sometimes it is not
specific regulations actions but simply
starting to articulate the bar the
example of the ipod I would argue is an
example of marketing no one really needs
that stupid device you know you know you
can listen to those 3,000 songs in rapid
fire on anything else but the fact that
somebody created a marketing machine
there they made you think that this is
what you want and that in a way needs to
be captured also from the policy
direction what about higher education
higher education is totally a fraud
right so that's why we're here yes the
issue is of course certain technology
you see the constituency behind or
piling or really and then you have a
business capacity to deploy because
there a number of a combination between
policy vision interest makes a
technology develop but in a number of
cases it's purely public good at the
start and and there I see I don't know
how you evaluate the capacity of
government these days of course being
European the capacity of the government
has really shrank to be able really to
have a vision of what really should
public programs be developing
universities in a high level education
institution to really put you that
public good and we see that in a health
sector where now more most of the
research is down to private
in the company's which which is good in
a way but but on the other side you lose
that public good dimension which is a
very important and sometimes you cannot
market everything and when I look at how
you you look at the picture of the
investment where r and v is now you see
a lot of sectors where for example on
agriculture in terms a new seeds or
water management of course you don't eat
as much economic interest as the other
sectors so I think that dimension and I
I think that in if we want to achieve
these different dimensional
sustainability there is a part of the
public goods air that it is we will need
and and in a moment where actually the
government's are not so much in capacity
to produce that public good it's an
interesting question I want to we'll
start with Professor HUD that on this
because the the issue I'd like to turn
to is this issue of the role of
government the role of private sector in
research and development which is
clearly at the the building block issue
here just to understand it the Earth
Institute and so I'm a lobbyist here we
get about a hundred million dollars a
year from the federal government in the
United States so it's not that the
United States has bailed out of
scientific research the National Science
Foundation National Institutes of Health
Noah NASA all of these the Department of
Energy all fund a variety of different
kind of research some of it very
fundamental a lot of it increasingly
applied but they are in that business
then there comes a point in the science
and technology development the R&D
development where it has commercial
potential and then it requires the
private sector participation the
personal computer the the internet all
of those technologies had fundamental
research that the government sponsored
then at some point it leaves the
government and goes into the private
sector so how do we get the
entrepreneurs into this and how can they
play a role in development in just a few
minutes let me answer that one
so so I think that there to pick up on
some themes that have already been
talked about the diffusion of
technologies takes a long time so as an
example the elements of the personal
computer were around for a long time
before there were personal computers
decades and and the and you have
examples of entrepreneurs that have kind
of launched too soon and then someone
else tries it again five or six years
later and are more successful so you
know Google wasn't the first and search
and I wasn't necessarily defending the
ipod i was just saying that's the number
of cookstoves i need to think about and
so how do I learn to be a marketer like
like Apple as well as a designer like
Apple for for our customers but butt on
the public private sector there are a
number of things so you you also see
some interesting clustering of
entrepreneurial activities so you know
there are hotbeds of entrepreneurship
and even industry-specific hotbeds of
entrepreneurship and those are starting
to shift although Silicon Valley is
still the dominant one but there's a lot
of concern around some of our government
policies for instance around immigration
and the effect that they're having on
our capacity to innovate because frankly
we in sourced a lot of our innovation
over the last 20 or 30 years and now
we're doing a pretty good job of rapidly
outsourcing it and then wondering where
the jobs went the entrepreneurs went
entrepreneurship is a team sport
entrepreneurship and innovation tends to
happen at the margins or boundaries of
fields and cultures so the more you can
throw disparate people together and get
them interacting the better that's I
think why universities have been good at
it and why there's some learnings about
how to make your university better at it
and so things like the Earth Institute
where we were talking about before they
started out with geology not a hotbed of
innovation right
changes you know every few you know
geological periods so so I I think
there's that I often there's this theme
to of we need more capital like
entrepreneurs aren't being capitalized
and that's an area government's like to
rush in and provide funding and and
there are examples where it's worked in
examples where it hasn't worked as well
I'd say one of the examples that it
seems to have worked quite well is
really the birth and dominance of the
United States and biotechnology through
a lot of work that was funded early by
the NIH as well as relying on you know
universities with medical schools that
didn't really have peers but as you look
around now and say well what where is
energy going to be or where are the next
technology is going to be nanotechnology
whereas stem cells going to move I mean
we've done a lot of things that that
have made innovation much more global
and I rejoice in that but I don't
believe all of our politicians rejoice
in that so there's a real tension of for
instance enviro fit is a global company
we're not a huge company we have tannish
employees in the US and 50 outside the
US that's probably a model for a lot of
entrepreneurial companies now and when
someone a congressperson shows up and
asks us how many more jobs we're going
to create in Colorado and the answer is
not many but we're going to create a lot
in Africa and India you don't really
want to get your picture taken with that
particular Congress person at that time
because they look like they just sucked
on a lemon it's an interesting point the
the issue of the global scientific
community and the global economy is one
that again in my own job in the earthen
still over the last four years I've been
struck by the degree to which the
research community doesn't know borders
doesn't think in those terms and in fact
resents it when we say well we have to
get that person of either they can't
stay here for two months and the need to
work on that issue is something that i
think i'm going to put aside for a
moment but i think is central professor
DC I think you were going to get into
this yeah I'd like to say something
about
I mean I think our d is fundamental and
I think these entrepreneurial energies
are great but when we're solving these
large collective problems like climate
disruption the entrepreneurs get
frustrated and die when there's no
policy to support it I seen that with
the solar industry in the United States
which is largely disappeared because
there's no support for it and by
contrast you know you have a lot of wind
being manufactured for the Danish market
and for the Texan market by the way
where there's a strong renewable
portfolio standard and I think in the
environmental area what you have to
understand is the government not
individual consumers is the source of
demand there are few exceptions that
organic agriculture is an exception to
that but you can improve your own health
by buying organic so there's sort of a
more like a an ordinary market process
there I think you're cookstove example
is similar where you know you can
improve your own health by using one of
these stoves so there's sort of an
appropriate benefit like like an iPad
offers but when you're talking about a
large global problem like climate
disruption you really need government
policy and I think important as R&D is
we can get awful lot by what economist
call learning by doing and that is the
the phenomenon that when there are a lot
of things out there like hybrid vehicle
is a perfect example the reason we have
hybrid vehicles is because of California
low emission vehicle standards they made
very difficult to comply with using
contorno combustion engines because they
were expensive before that the
manufacturers all had rd going on they
all had wonderful prototypes they had
electric cars they had all this stuff
but they weren't producing any of it
they said it was too expensive nobody
would buy it well then you have a policy
it says guys you're going to have to
produce something really low emission
and all of a sudden that they're
figuring out there the instead of the
billing these little bit of resources
into sort of research it's becoming a
major manufacturing to as a central
focus of the company to figure out how
to make these things cheap enough so
that people can afford them and all of a
sudden you have things my toyota prius
is a pretty moderately priced vehicle
that actually gets 45 or 50 miles per
gallon and so that the policy is really
important and one thing that really
bought
others me about where the United States
is at this moment is we used to believe
in our entrepreneurs we used to believe
that if we set ambitious goals if we had
good policies then we would figure out a
way to do it and drive down the cost of
doing things like going to the moon
right and we seem to no longer believe
that we think if we if we have any
government regulation of any tax of any
policy at all some intolerable and
inescapable burden a permanent cost that
will never be escaped when we put on the
pot on the polity and it just isn't true
I think it's historically entrepreneurs
have risen these demands and figured out
how to do these things I think we have a
very unsafe levels like I mean what
entrepreneurs want is some
predictability business wants some
predictability so if there were a price
on carbon which I understand is is
evidently very hard for the US
government to do and and Europe's done
it with some success but it's it's still
a young market but I keep hoping that
their policies that get races to the top
as opposed to races to the bottom and
right now in the environment
governmental area I think there's more
of a race to the bottom major obstacle
we have and I think you just pointed to
it in this country which you don't see
in Europe is this ideological view of
anything government does to interact
with the market is somehow going to be
destructive every single piece of
regulatory legislation that you hear
about is now called a job-killing bill
even if an ineffective actually will
create whole new markets so I think I
think we're in agreement on that the
question is how do we build the level of
sophistication in this country to a
place which is at least closer to what
we see in Europe right now why don't we
have our two Europeans talk to us about
that for sure don't be so sure you
gather for sure when oil will go again
to 140 and when it will get 200 you'll
get it there and that is one hundred
percent sure we are talking about an
externality and when there is an
externality there is a case for
government intervention
now government intervention in what even
here in our discussion we've been
talking about government intervention
for R&D for example to environment
climate change now in a moment where the
rate of unemployment is almost ten
percent in the US where you are
concerned with foreclosures where
european countries are on their knees
because the euro may explode when China
is growing at this pace now send selling
an agenda for policy change and for
financing R&D based on soft issues like
environment and climate change in my
view that ism that is a mistake and that
is a mistake of the US and not only now
I would like to tell a very interesting
discussion I had the other day in my
class we were debating China and the US
and we arrived this is a big problem
ninety ninety percent of the increase in
demand will come from non-oecd countries
China sure that they are building a lot
of coal power plants and the answer of a
Chinese student was the father no
problem you invent the new technologies
we copy and you sell it back to you so
this is the challenge we face because
the problems will come from there but
they will have an impact in India a cd-r
their little garages in Beijing like
they had in in Silicon Valley professor
of course in u.s. like in Europe Europe
was different but not that different
with the idea that you have really to
withdraw from the welfare state that
public spending was you know even if we
spend a lot was not really the good
thing that government will always cherry
picking you're making mistakes on on
research and development on the same at
the same time or and now given that
ideology which i think is quite shared
even if there is an idea that we could
have a collective effort in Europe to to
develop our MD the ideas that
really government should play a big role
is really not there but at the same time
of course I Anna is developing the zero
totally opposite muddle where there's a
push and pull is very much about pool
and the government is of course with
different system different structural
different different regimes on parks and
and the public enterprise you see an
enormous amount of subsidies to this new
technology not maybe on the top only a
high range but that you see now the what
is a country investing more on on
renewable is is clearly China of course
there is a size aspect but you know in
research the size makes makes it all so
in a way I think we will confront with
how views in Europe and in us where the
private sector will have the lead and
the government should refrain from some
pointing direction and this confronted
with an economy with the Russian and
it's totally different and I don't know
what would be the outcome but I see in
China you you see that everywhere in
China there's a university is the
capacity they have to to receive funding
is really incredible and we will see of
course now I understand that some trade
unions here wants to sue China in front
of the ability or on the base of the
subsidies to renewable industry be
school of course China is exporting all
the solar panel in Europe and in US but
we will have this model confronting in
global level and it's very much about
global global issues and global R&D and
in global markets and what do we do if
China decided to do so do do we should
just sit in and look at them I don't
know interesting question at this point
I wanted to open up the QA to members of
the audience so if what we've had to say
so far seems interesting or provocative
if you'd like to I guess would you like
them to go to the microphone if they
have a question okay because I think
they're taping this of any any questions
please come to the microphone and and
address them to to our panelists or we
achieve perfect understanding on all of
these issues already yeah go ahead why
don't you head over there and perhaps
that yeah right in the middle there
there's a there's a microphone I think
they want you to speak it yes well
you'll conserve energy is I want to
touch upon the the the last remarks on
China because it seems to me that it is
the how do they say english is not my
native language 800-pound gorilla in the
indian room the they have a well i mean
dude you don't need to be an expert as i
am not but just reading religiously well
tom friedman you get the impression that
they will overtake the us in that
particular field of renewable energy
technology but on the other hand the
theory goes that the the kind of regime
that they have does not is not very
inimical to to research because well i
don't need to go into okay so the
question for the panel is what what do
we do but it's China model and what do
we do with will they'll overtake the
West or but particularly the u.s. in
that indicator is it a foot race anybody
money right I won't prognosticate on who
will win but I will say that I think at
least one perspective might be aren't we
fortunate to have another billion people
that are thinking about these issues and
innovating and when did we the advantage
the relative advantage of our country
and our politics versus others so if
they can actually figure out how to make
really low cost efficient solar panels
more low-cost that if
then we that maybe what we need to get
to the 25-percent solar or renewables
that dr. Pena was was talking about I
think they have other challenges I the
middle class across the world is going
to grow by 1.8 billion people over the
next 10 12 years that's astonishing it's
and and do those people all have the
homes and the lifestyles that have the
fifty percent energy conservation built
into them or do they take the most
wasteful models and that sway we were
focused a lot on the developed
industrialized world right now but the
problem is going to be shifting to
wherever those 1.8 billion people are
they aren't all in China a lot are but
they're in Brazil and they're in
Indonesia and there are other places and
to dinner to try to deny them their
right to use the markets to purchase the
same resources we're going after seems
unlikely so I it's an interesting point
also whether or not we are in fact in
such an interdependent global economy
and political economy at this point that
the old model of us and them may not
really work because there's so much
interdependency in this system that in
effect it's almost like we have were
enabler zuv each other you know the with
the the the Chinese government and the
Chinese entrepreneurs and capitalists
can't really afford to see the middle
class the United States destroyed
because they'll be destroying their own
markets there's where I sit the
perspective is we're already working
with Chinese companies to make our cook
stoves and it's it's so much more
complicated than like where does the
innovation arise and where does it get
sold because so many innovations and I
think so many more innovations are going
to kind of be sourced globally and you
know Columbia can work with the
University in India which I mean those
things are happening I they didn't
happen 20 years ago so I'm pull as
opposed to despairing David
I don't really have much to add to that
I think we are very interdependent I
think it's a profound challenge what do
we do about the decline of blue-collar
employment in the US but I don't think
the answer is to cut off development in
China that just doesn't make sense to me
you know the mentality in the United
States still is that we are the leaders
in technological innovation and China
copies us and Chinese products are
subpar but what inexpensive the reality
is that the incentives that china is
putting in place for their technology
development far outweigh what we see the
United States and the products that are
coming out our innovations beyond what
you get here simple but innovative we
have another question here yeah my
question is related to energy so last
year the house representatives passed an
energy bill but it's stalled in the
Senate because not a single Republican
senator wanted to sign on or tackle the
issue but yet the planet still warms and
the environment gets worse how does the
US catch up in terms of energy
development and improve our energy
policy and approach to carbon emissions
when now Obama is dealing with an
ideologically split House and Senate
anybody want to take a crack at that
well it's it's not going to be possible
but there will be there may be progress
from states and local governments on
these issues and in fact historically
energy policy is a state government
issuance of California you know it's a
pretty important center of innovation
the Obama administration is also likely
to do some things by executive action it
already has a very significant thing
that it did was to adopt automobile
standards that are modeled after the
California Standards so you're going to
see big big improvements and we've
already seen this helping our
manufacturers actually because their
their their step they're not being so
retrograde anymore they're stepping up
and getting up in front a little more on
the energy trends it's starting to make
advanced vehicles which they never did
before so I think there's going to be
some progress
in spite of the fact that it's
impossible to get good climate
legislation right now from the EPA in
the States but it's not going to be
enough is the problem is so huge you
really do need the federal government to
step up and that that's going to happen
when you folks get out there and demand
it oh yeah i would i would say the EPA
is in fact moving to regulate greenhouse
gases and you'll see that I think the
state issue is actually more interesting
new york state for example taxes your
electric bill now it's generating about
a half a billion dollars a year which is
going back into energy efficiency
projects by and large California's been
doing that for almost a decade and
generates well over a billion dollars a
year from the same kind of taxation so I
think you are going to see state and
local activity but let's let's hear from
the rest of the panel might suggest and
if i have any of a very good friend of
the united states is to put some what
the global warming agenda the back seat
because there are other agendas which
are no less important and that they mean
something to the American people for
example the agenda of energy security
and that of competitiveness over the
next 20 years revenue of OPEC countries
are estimated to increase by five by
five where the main or the main oil
reserves in the world is Iraq Iran
Venezuela and the like China is buying
all all assets in oil this means
something to to to to to the US and I
think that strengthening the agenda for
change with arguments that are not
related with global warming that can
produce a positive effect on sister
sustainability and global warming okay
there are other questions behind you
sure so we we've discussed how
sustainable is a process and how there's
me a lot of little steps leading up to
that but like most breakthroughs in
technology
we seen last hundred years maybe atomic
bomb or going to the moon there's been a
singularity or a moment that's caused
that push like World War 2 or john f
kennedy making a proclamation that we
should and aside from two-hundred-dollar
oil I've heard I've not yet heard any
other speculation about what may cause a
singularity that will cause the
transition from or that great human push
from the world we're in now to a
sustainable world I was wondering aside
from the proposed to her dollars in oil
and we're on our last steps against the
cliff what could possibly cause that for
us further to be on how we're going to
save the world well if we should if they
have known we could we certainly would
be nice to them to know how we make that
push all that pool I don't know what the
direction we should take that what do we
have in front of us a mixed of groups in
countries who really think that it is a
way to go and you see them everywhere
there's no I think no one country no one
been country at what level that doesn't
think about having really a
sustainability agenda Chinese five years
ago I meet a member of a Chinese Council
on Environment and we advise a prime
minister and see him every year five
years ago one sitting in this council
the idea was for China 2020 now it has
changed totally and you don't see any
developing countries who is not thinking
about this energy policy and the climate
policy but of course it's only a groups
are very concepts which doesn't think
that it is a right way to go even even
in China where battles are very foot
very strongly for example around the
stimulus package and nowadays on the 12
year plan so I think we have everywhere
people who see the vision is there and
it needs we are still in inner
discussion which we have to sort of it
to to develop and to to fight for we you
will have to fight for that vision and
and we begin to see some economic
interest who really see the same and
that's good that the UH global companies
that Cesar direction and also of course
are much more conservative but the sea
change in the automobile industry here
in us there was a more conservative at
the world level and now because of
course crisis and certainly but internal
debate within these big companies of
what was the right model so we are
exactly in the middle of this discussion
or fight or whatever you want to qualify
it and as I think the only way we we
don't have one mechanism the only way is
really to go and demonstrate and argue
and try to to to sort of create business
I but there is no central solution I
think that's an excellent point that if
we had this conversation if had this
conversation 20 years ago and if we did
it would have been a corner of room 1401
or something like that we wouldn't have
been up here I actually started the
environmental concentration at sepa 1987
and it was me and for people so I guess
the the point i think is a good one that
we may be in the middle of this
transition right now and your awareness
and the the sense of the importance of
the issue is in fact the part of the
process that we shouldn't underestimate
um next question dr. allow and threat
the dialogue you mentioned the role of
multinationals in achieving things like
carbon neutrality and water neutrality
assume you're referring to companies
like Pepsi in and some of their
innovation they're really driving does
and the question for you and the other
panelist is does the public sector have
a role in catalyzing innovation in
multinationals or are they by definition
beyond the role of the public sector now
I think they definitely have a role in
catalyzing it's in a way I'll go back to
the point that Paul made you know its
marketing paid and a comment that the
King of Bhutan once made is that
he banned advertising in the country
because he said the only goal of
advertising is to make you feel
inadequate to buy something so if you
can actually use that to your advantage
here and you make people feel that
essentially they're going to lose the
planet unless they do some things then
you know that marketing angle works in
both directions so I think that's the
push-pull between the multinationals the
environmental groups and the public
sector okay hi my name is Shimek bose
I'm a first year student here at ciba
and you know I wish there was a class on
how to market to the bottom of the
pyramid I thought I think you'll be
really interesting and seatbelt and the
reason why I bring this up is that you
know when you look at the bottom of the
pyramid as you say the equation is
completely different right there's these
huge scales and the prices have to be
drastically shifted as well because
people that are on consuming a dollar a
day can they really afford to buy the
gas stove that you currently mentioned
so I guess my question is you know is
that in that analysis is that when a
global public good can be created such
as a inventors incentive fund so new
inventors can enter the market and the
stability for the invention is
guaranteed by governments that hey if
you do discover something that will work
then we'll step in and buy the product
from you so is there a way for the two
sides to speak thank you David the
professor tobyhanna maybe a for the
moment totally in this new sector of
energy and energy efficiency and
decarbonisation we don't for the moment
maybe we don't have innovative models of
a relation between government and
private sector but when you look at the
health issue again this year's because
of malaria treatments or AIDS or more on
disease were not really there's no
private research on them then we found
through innovative foundation logic gate
foundation there was a lot of discussion
Jeff Sachs
here has a lot of initiative to create
how could be the new model of research
knowing that the private sector has the
information so it's not is they have to
do it but you have to create a new
incentive model to for them to be
interested in these new diseases and I
think we have to look for these models
because in a way the companies have to
have very different business model too
we have a very interesting conversation
with a major electricity company in
France which which I am advising
sometimes and the idea is how you will
sell less electricity and more energy
services which is how you sell less and
less electricity and more and more
energy services that's the way your new
business model should be and that again
we are in the middle of the discussion
here and I see where if we could invent
new models of relations that looking at
the health sector I think it was
interesting that I think that could help
it's not the old generation may be on
pull and push system Lanka of government
on the 70s maybe that's all the models
but we should be quick to invent them
anyway okay I think we have time for one
more question if there is one and then
we'll do our wrap-up so please good
afternoon everybody else as Professor
Cohen mentioned these conversation would
have not taken place a couple of years
ago and I feel that there's a big role
in putting the environmental issues into
policy discussions thanks to scientists
so I was I was my question is what is
the role of scientists in the policy
world and if they should what should
they do what is the role I think we only
have one scientist here right mono so
you're going to have to speak for your
whole community like I know the depends
on what you call science if the if there
if science is the pursuit of truth right
which is the same as the goal of
religion sometimes depending on how you
define religion
and I think science is the flag bearer
of advance warning of possible outcomes
as well as the tool by which people can
be guided as to the feasibility of
certain goals you know the individual
who asked about landing on the moon
probably someone thought about landing
on the moon as a good idea in 5000 BC
but could not execute it so it's at a
certain point science gets to the stage
where you can say yes this is feasible
and hence you need to now be able to do
something and I think that's the
fundamentally the role that scientists
can play what they should play is a
value judgment scary from that okay
first I want to before the panel even
begins their summation I want to thank
everybody involved and it's been a very
interesting conversation I'm going to
ask each of the panelists to give us
some concluding thoughts about the role
of Technology in sustainable development
from their own perspective and then I
understand after that we're going to
have a reception and so I'm always aware
of the fact that I don't want to be
between a group of students and liquor
so I'm cognizant of the need to sum this
up to get to your reception so well so
I'll build on the young man who asked
about marketing for the vop class
because I'm always afraid with forums
and conferences that we just talk about
things and nothing happens so I will
challenge you guys to figure out how to
make that happen at Columbia there are
lots or growing number of faculty that
are teaching classes like that so the
syllabi are out there so you just need
to go find a faculty member who's
willing to kind of put themselves out
there and maybe expand not just to the
blp but how to use marketing as my
colleague dr. Lal has been talking about
to achieve good and and maybe look at
whether marketing really is just about
creating needs for things or once for
things that you don't need or whether
marketing has
other roles to to me what we're facing
is is where we need policymakers we need
scientists we need businesspeople all to
be working and with great urgency the
business as usual isn't working and I
understand as a businessperson
businesses the first part of business as
usual and it's a it's a it's a great
challenge for me I look at it this is a
time of a lot of opportunity but it's
also probably a time of a lot of
destruction in terms of destroying some
of the things that don't work as well
and i hearken back to what an economy
does is trade in goods and services and
we've totally lost our anchor to both
those words if you as you think about
them so think of companies whose goods
are really good or think of companies
whose services really serve it's a short
list and I'd encourage you all to be
involved in thinking about working for
the ones where their goods are good or
we're starting ones that do that thank
you for SLO so there's this thing I've
heard since I was a kid which is the
meek shall inherit the earth and I
always wondered what they were trying to
get me to understand and I realized that
perhaps what they're trying to tell me
is that the evidence is that the meek
are coming in lost in everything that
you see but I guess another way to look
at that saying is that if points are
essentially what we have learned from
biodiversity anytime we have an
ecological system which turns to
monoculture eventually it vanishes and
if you have a mix of strategies if you
have a mix of groups trying to look at
these problems then you end up with a
more stable situation so whether we look
at the policy side or the technology
side or countries such as China or
countries such as Bangladesh strategies
pursued by different groups are somewhat
different and I think the richness of
maintaining that is somewhat important
if you're looking at sustainability of
the planet so if you take all the
questions that people were asking and
and say what is the right thing my
answer is there is not one dry
thing we have to keep playing this game
and we'll keep bashing our head and 0
against the wall and survive that's
Julian oh I think we are facing a very
big challenge because of this variety or
this diverse point of views it diverse
models and the globalization where we
are so dependent there is a very nice
video on YouTube really I advise you to
look at which is about China in us and
it's called we are a codependent economy
it's very funny it's about of what the
currency war but we are in that type of
work and I see there from this very
specific point of view when I'm working
in the climate talks but we need to make
the different country the different
groups understand what the other is
doing and not in a sort of bashing way
but understanding the different models
that are at work and I suggest that task
of which is very much an intellectual
work but a communication work and
information work too is essential
because we need to really combine
different intelligences and understand
that the choices may be different but to
build a common vision to build common
anticipation which is when we need to go
to this sustainability development model
we need to understand the differences
and I see that the point where well
maybe there is a huge efforts to to to
make but we to build converging views we
have to accept the differences and we
are not there and second I would say
that it's fascinating how the your
generation are really pushing us I
remember my first classes in in Incheon
spawn environment we're very sort of the
alphabetization how things are and how
much we have water problem and food
problems and nowadays and the concern
that people should be really the
constants of consciousness and awareness
of on the risks and that was
time that was difficult to get the same
vision of the risk and now my students
say well showed that part of the course
is we we we don't need to know why
people doesn't have the same vision of
the receipt we we already know that we
we know that the risk are there we are
you don't have to convince us and why
it's so difficult for your generation to
have a common vision a common assessment
of the risk and that is I think the main
difference and in this country maybe use
a representative in the Senate or in the
house are not that conscious but you are
so I think those things with which end
very quickly okay fresh opinion well
firstly once again thank you very much
it's a privilege to be in this panel and
facing you so thank you very much
Columbia again then regarding technology
we need a road map and the set plan the
new energy era that I came here that I
brought you to you is exactly that it's
not the specific matters but it's a
roadmap we need the vision of the new
energy era of the of the future I think
that in this discussion we have
strengthened our agreement on what
matters now is China China China so
without taking into account what will
happen in China it's not possible to
frame our energy and environment policy
because what we do impacts on China what
China does impact in the rest of the
world and is such an order of magnitude
that what will happen there will be
really determined to last small
suggestions please don't continue the
mistake on putting all the emphasis on
the environment that doesn't happen in
Europe Europe s on the environment side
probably a policy which is more advanced
than in the US but the reason for that
is that number one we have very high
taxes on full on gasoline and number two
because we for us the problem of energy
security it's much stronger than that
than here so this suggestion don't put
all the weight on sustainability and
lastly as an European it's almost the
first time in my life that I participate
in a meeting where Europe is praised
relative to the US so you cannot imagine
from me it's really a privilege well the
food the food has been better for a long
time very well I think we've left the
error we're just getting more and more
stuff produces more prosperity I mean
that's not what's happening the United
States the middle class has declined
joblessness is increased because of
mindless senseless useless and financial
innovation now what we need is
innovation in particular direction to
determine Daly's idea innovation that
will reduce the throughput as we produce
a good life for people and that's going
to require a real change in attitude in
this country ought to make that come
about and that attitude is sort of a
prerequisite for having effective
climate policy to create the climate
where entrepreneurs will produce the
innovations and refine them to bring
down the cost of doing what we need to
do about climate disruption so I do urge
all of you to go out there and work
really hard to try to produce that that
change in attitude is right now we don't
seem to be capable of doing the most
elementary things and I agree with what
was said by the way it's not just about
environment it's about jobs we're not
going to have jobs if we just continue
to use every last drop of oil until it
disappears that just won't work ok thank
you I'll put in a last word from my own
perspective as the panels were talking I
was thinking about New York City where
some of the things that we've been
talking about the
that needs to happen have in fact
started and why well first forty percent
of the people that live in New York City
were born in other countries if you
include people who are here illegally
it's probably closer to fifty percent if
you include the million students in New
York City on any given college students
actually college and graduate students
we have about a million elementary
school through high school students here
just in the public system this is the
post-industrial global city we used to
make things in New York we don't make
very many things here anymore we make
ideas and we bring people together from
all over the world to talk about policy
to think about things this isn't going
to be the only thing that's done here
but it is one of the main things it's
done here so i actually have and i think
it was Professor to be honor that said
this I have confidence because of you
and because of the characteristics of
the city that brings groups like this
together and has done that and is in
fact institutionalizing it in the
universities here and in the media here
and of course in the United Nations and
so I have a high level of confidence
that we are going to make this
transition I'm always reminded of of
Malthus prediction that we'd all be
starving by now which didn't turn out to
be the case because of Technology so in
fact there will be some of these changes
it's not going to be simple and
straightforward but I want to commend
the journal of international affairs
which is you know a very unique
institution and of itself in taking on
these issues the journals over the last
several years been taking on all the
tough issues and I was walking through
the lobby earlier today and seeing all
the old journal covers from back in the
beginning era and some of the issues of
people were discussing and it's clear
that the study of international affairs
as reflected by the journal started
quite narrowly and of course coming off
of World War two the focus on security
issues was an obvious one but it's now
broadened to all of these issues of
sustainable development
in fact I'm incredibly encouraged by it
and encouraged by the discussion we had
here tonight and your ability to attract
all these great people here and I'm even
more encouraged by the fact that you SAT
patiently while of that food and drink
was sitting in in the lounge there so
again thank you everybody a wonderful
event and congratulations would you
please join me in thanking our wonderful
panel tonight please